this video is sponsored by equals I
think there's this notion that making
money is evil right it's like rooted all
the way back down to money is the root
of all evil people think that the
bankers steal our money and you know
it's somewhat true in that in a lot of
the world there's a lot of theft going
on all the time the history of the world
in some sense is this Predator prey
relationship between makers and takers
there are people who go out and create
things and build things and work hard on
things then there are people who come
along and play with a sword or a gun or
taxes or a crony capitalism or communism
or what have you there's all these
different methods to steal even in
nature there are more parasites than
there are non-parasitical organisms you
have ton of parasites in you who are
living off of you and the better ones
are symbiotic they're giving something
back but they're a lot that are just
taking that's just the nature of how any
complex system is built but what I am
focused on is true wealth creation it's
not about taking money it's not about
taking something from somebody else but
it's from creating a bunch abundance
obviously there's not a finite number of
jobs or a finite amount of wealth
otherwise we'll still be sitting around
in caves figuring out how to divide up
pieces of firewood and you know the
occasional dead deer so most of the
wealth and civilization in fact not most
all of it has been created and it got
created from somewhere it got created
from people it got created from
technology got critical productivity got
created from hard work so this idea that
is stolen is I think this horrible
zero-sum game that people who are trying
to gain status play but the reality is
everyone can be rich it is merely a
question of education and desire you
have to want it if you don't want it
that's fine then you opt out of the game
but don't try and put down the people
who are playing the game because that's
the game that keeps you in a comfortable
warm bed at night that's the game that
keeps a roof over your head that's a
game that keeps your supermarket stock
that's the game that keeps the iPhone
buzzing in your pocket so it is a
beautiful game that is worth playing
ethically rationally morally socially
for the human race and it's going to to
continue to make us all richer and
richer until we have massive wealth
creation for anybody who wants it so
wealth is a very positive sum game we
create things together we're starting
this endeavor to create this hopefully
piece of art that explains what we're
doing at the end of it something brand
new will be created it's a positive sum
game status on the other hand is a zero
seven game it's a very old game we've
been playing it since monkey tribes and
it's hierarchical who's number one who's
number two who's number three and for
number three to move to number two
number two has to move out of that slot
so status is zero-sum game politics is
an example of a status game even Sports
is an example of a status game to be the
winner there must be a loser I don't
fundamentally love status games they
play an important role in our society so
we figure out who's in charge but
fundamentally you play them because
they're a necessary evil the problem is
on an evolutionary basis like if you go
back thousands of years status is a much
better predictor of survival than wealth
is you couldn't have wealth before the
farming age for Farmers because you
couldn't store things hunter-gatherers
carried everything on their backs so
hunter-gatherers lived entirely in
status based societies Farmers started
going to wealth-based Societies in the
modern industrial economies are much
more heavily wealth-based societies but
there's always a subtle competition
going on between status and wealth for
example when journalists attack rich
people or that attack the technology
industry they're really bidding for
status they're saying no the people are
more important and I the journalist
represents the people and therefore I am
more important the problem is that by
playing these status games to win the
status game you have to put somebody
else down that's why you should avoid
status games in your life because they
make you into an angry combative person
you're always fighting to put other
people down to put yourself and the
people that you like up and they're
always going to exist there's no way
around it but just realize that most of
the times when you're trying to create
wealth you're actually getting attacked
by someone else and they're trying to
look like a goody two shoes but really
what they're doing is they're trying to
up their own status at your expense I
think people have to be very careful to
not get trapped along the way with
things that you can afford with your
current lifestyle like the way you're
living and the way you're earning but
they're also imprisoning you and the
fact that you are now going to have to
work this 40-hour week job in order to
get this thing that you can't afford but
now you're saddled down to this job
you've no you're not saving you're not
you're not putting things in a good
place and you're working for these
things working for things as rewards is
a real trap that a lot of people fall
into it's the biggest one you know
that's even telev also says that uh you
know there are two great addictions
heroin and a monthly salary
right and and that's why you can't get
rich renting out your time because even
when you start charging more and more
for your time it's a slow upgrade Loop
and then you upgrade your house at the
same time and you pick your car at the
same time you move in the neighborhood
you really also have to get used to
ignoring your peers or upgrading or
changing the definition of your peers a
lot of people here who are poor here but
they would be rich if they were living
in Thailand and Bali and if they have
the luxury of a remotely doable job they
may want to be living there
and saving up money well the ignoring
the peers is an issue because the
Keeping Up With the Jones is a real
phenomenon yeah Envy makes the world go
around right yeah how does one Escape
nine to five
um
so uh escaping the nine to five grind is
actually very difficult uh and one of
the big problems that many of us have in
life and I face this early on too is you
you just get sucked into being busy and
you get something to be busy because you
have a job the job kind of chews up all
of your time from 9am to 5 p.m you get
home you're exhausted how are you
supposed to work on anything else
so uh I I think the key there is trying
to find a career or a job or an
education where you will end up in a
business where the inputs and the
outputs are disconnected
but what I mean by that is
um let's say that you're growing up in
uh you know the World 2000 years ago
almost all the jobs you could have back
then the inputs and the outputs are very
tightly connected so if you go and you
uh you know you have to go cut wood you
spend four hours cutting Woods you get
four hours worth of cutting wood output
uh there'll be very slight difference
between the two but nowadays you have
knowledge worker jobs you have
intellectual jobs uh programming being
my favorite example where a good
developer can write a piece of code that
can literally make your business
hundreds of millions of dollars for the
next few years and there are developers
who can who can write code all day long
and you know just because they're
creating the wrong thing it's actually
not creating value no matter how hard
they work so yeah customers don't care
about inputs they only care about
outcomes and outputs so if you can if
you can navigate towards a career where
you're tracked on the output you're
going to do much better what are
examples of career so I give coding's
example but actually sales is another
one doesn't examples and especially very
expensive sales very high end sales so
like if you're out there for example if
you're selling houses if you're a real
estate agent right not a great job
necessarily very very crowded but if
you're a Top Flight real estate agent
you know how to Market yourself you know
how to sell houses it's possible you
could sell five million dollar mansions
in a tenth the time that somebody else
is struggling to sell hundred thousand
dollar apartments or condos so that is a
job where input and output are highly
disconnected
coding and sales what else well actually
building any product and selling any
product and fundamentally what else is
there so what you don't necessarily want
to be in is a a support role like a
customer service kind of role for
example customer service unfortunately
inputs and outputs map relatively
closely towards each other the amount of
hours put in matters so it helps to move
towards things that have these uh skill
sets where it's pretty hard to match it
in close to outputs
of course all the people selling get
rich quick advice you know for twenty
dollars like that's all complete
nonsense all the people giving you stock
tips or crypto tips on Twitter complete
nonsense
um these are all fake signals there are
no get rich quick schemes that's just
somebody else trying to get rich off of
you it's surprising to me actually how
many people fall for them it's kind of
sad well yeah why why do you think
people fall for that there's a certain
desperation and a certain hunger for
money in our society which I kind of
feel bad about which is why I did you
know partially all the how to get rich
work to help people figure out the
principles of making money or creating
wealth I should say
um it's the people are so desperate for
how to figure that out that even when
they know that this thing is probably
scammy it's probably a waste of time
this guy probably doesn't know what he's
talking about he might have a good
tidbit in there right they're so
desperate and it's it's a little sad
because making money as I was saying
it's an inevitable byproduct of learning
Ben Franklin has a he has many great
quotes many great sayings one of his
sayings is this
is many people die at 25 but they are
not buried till they are 75. what does
he mean by that statement what did Ben
Franklin mean by that what he meant by
that is
that from the age of 26 to 75
it was a living corpse
and what he meant by that is that what
happens with a lot of humans
is that they stop learning
when they finish school and that's
probably one of the worst things you can
do in terms of your development so when
Franklin says that many people die at 25
and are buried at 75 it means that at 25
they stop growing and stop learning
and so what happens with a lot of people
who go to
IIT or a lot of elite institutions
they don't go very far in life even
though they did really well academically
and the reason they don't go very far in
life is because they are not learning
machines they have just learned what
they knew in school and then they
stopped learning I would say that the
most important skill to getting rich is
becoming a Perpetual learner okay you
have to know how to learn anything you
want to learn there should be no book in
the library that scares you whether it's
a math book or a physics book or
electrical engineering book or a
sociology book or an economics book you
should be able to take any book down off
the shelf and read it and guess what a
number of them are going to be too
difficult for you that's okay read them
anyway then go back and reread them and
reread them when you have when you're
reading a book and you're not
understanding a lot of what it's saying
and there's a lot of confusion in your
mind about it that that confusion is
similar to the pain the burn that you
get in a gym when you're working out
your but this time you're building
mental muscles instead of building
physical muscles so just learn how to
learn and and read the hard books and
now let me leave you with some
Reflections stop learning after school
quote from Charlie Monger I constantly
see people rise in life who are not the
smartest sometimes not even the most
diligent but they are learning machines
they go to bed every night a little
wiser than they were when they got up
and boy does that help particularly when
you have a long rung ahead of you end of
quote quote from Navara vacant if you're
a Perpetual learning machine you will
never be out of options for how to make
money you can always see what's coming
up in society what the value is where
the demand is and you can learn to come
up to speed end of quote ultimately the
most common way to escape the rat race
is to be an entrepreneur and build
businesses and there's never been a
better time to be an entrepreneur in
words of shopify's President remember
remember that the cost of failure right
now is the lowest it's ever been in the
history of the world and the reason for
this is that in today's world you have
free leverage at your disposal your
website app or media content are
essentially assets that can earn while
you sleep in words of Navarro weekend so
an army of robots is already here it's
very cheaply available and the
bottleneck is just figuring out
intelligent and interesting things to do
to them and the way out of this
bottleneck is to be a Perpetual learner
now a quick word from today's video
sponsor equals equals is the only
spreadsheet with built-in connections to
any database and many apps with
versioning collaboration and direct
access to gpt4 for auto feeling
and it works just like Excel or sheets
so you already know how to use it
equals is backed by David Sachs and is
loved by operators from the most
Innovative companies click the link in
the description to try out equals for
free